[Music]  [Music]  my brother gave his life hunting the  enemy his task is now mine  speak your truth  [Music]  stand with me  ours was no chance meeting  searching  not fate  nor destiny  ours was the work of something greater  [Music]  each of us  everyone  must decide who  we shall be  [Music]  i am not the hero you sink  whatever it was you did  be free of it  one day this will be your kingdom raise  your sail  and then let go  choose not the path of fear  but that of faith  [Music]  one thing we can do  better than any creature in all middle  earth  we stay true to each other  our hearts  even bigger in our feet  [Music]  i can survive this  you are not  commander wait no we keep moving  why do you keep fighting  there is a tempest in me  [Music]  you have fought long enough galatria put  up your sword  [Music]  without it what might be  [Music]  you